salud en directo américa de france 24 me
acompaña en el estudio más romeros a la
mar bienvenida en esta sección especial
de salud con invitado al día porque
vamos a hablar de las patentes de las
vacunas contra el cohete sino de los
tratamientos o contra esta enfermedad y
el nuevo acuerdo además que llegó la
organización mundial del comercio no
buenos días es raúl efectivamente como
habíamos hablado ya es un acuerdo para
levantar temporalmente estas patentes
que pesan sobre las vacunas contra el
cubit 19 recordemos además con una
patente pues es ese acuerdo ese papel
que hace que cuando un productor
registra un producto nadie más lo pueda
hacer esto es lo que se ha levantado de
forma temporal durante cinco años para
muchas partes digamos que es positivo es
un paso adelante porque permite a países
en vías de desarrollo producir estas
vacunas estamos hablando por ejemplo de
india también de sudáfrica eso hace que
las vacunas sean mucho más baratas
también para otros países y que las
hagan más accesibles pero también habían
habido críticas por parte de la sociedad
civil de organizaciones como médicos sin
fronteras que denuncian que es un
acuerdo mucho más a tímido de lo que
podría haber sido realmente de la
propuesta inicial de sudáfrica y de
india porque por ejemplo no incluye pues
los tratamientos las medicinas las
herramientas diagnósticas como los tests
por ejemplo para luchar contra la
pandemia entonces bueno por ahora este
es el debate que existe y además también
dicen que le vamos a analizar más
adelante que este acuerdo llegó muy
tarde marc pero porque un acuerdo así
era tan necesario pues digamos que como
decíamos al menos desde una perspectiva
de salud pública lo que hace levantar
las patentes es que estos accesos a las
vacunas al menos por ahora sólo las
vacunas sean mucho más rápidos y mucho
más fáciles no cuando se inventaron
recordemos y cuando primero aparecieron
los países que tenían esa producción en
sus propios países lo que tenían los
recursos para comprarlas se hicieron con
millones y millones de vacunas incluso
más de las que necesitaban para vacunar
a su población en unas dinámicas de
acaparamiento y lo que pasó fue que los
países con menos recursos tuvieron que
esperar meses a poder empezar sus
campañas de vacunación dejando pues
desprotegidos a gran parte grandes
porcentajes de sus habitantes y haciendo
que la espalda pandemia empeorará en sus
países muchas veces también además de
esperar para comprarlas también tuvieron
que esperar para recibir donaciones
vamos a ver ahora las cifras de un
ejemplo que es el continente africano
del que hemos hablado también varias
veces recordemos sobre un 17% de la
población africana ahora mismo está
completamente inmunizada contra el
commit 19 vemos aquí a bates un fondo de
la unión africana que hicieron para
comprar vacunas y donar las de los
países falta el 93 3 por ciento de todas
las vacunas que habían que se habían
propuesto donar y en el caso de kóvacs
la iniciativa de la s se ha logrado
menos también de la mitad del objetivo
algo que nos habla de que realmente este
sistema de compra en los países ricos y
luego donaciones es muy ineficiente
luego una brevemente otras cifras donde
vemos otras desigualdades desde en
cuanto a la producción de las vacunas
vemos que mientras que en áfrica sólo se
produce el 16 por ciento de las vacunas
en europa estamos hablando del 86 por
ciento de las vacunas que se producen en
su territorio sudamericano está exenta
estamos hablando de aproximadamente 15
por ciento de vacunas que se producen en
su territorio y esto pues que nos dice
nos dice que son territorios ampliamente
dependientes y que son precisamente los
países con menos recursos los que más
tienen que importar más de pregunto
para ya antes de pasar a nuestro
invitado el llenos invita al día la
primera vez que se un acuerdo como éste
pues con tantas negociaciones bombo y
platillo' dificultades así pero no es la
primera vez que en fármacos en este caso
vacunas que podrían solucionar crisis
globales se han renunciado a las
patentes y por eso queríamos recordar
también brevemente la historia de la
historia de jonas salk que es el hombre
que inventó la primera vacuna contra la
polio y cuando le preguntaron pues de
quién era esta vacuna él lo que
respondió era que la vacuna era la gente
y se preguntó si realmente un bien común
como el sol también se podría patentar
entonces pues para él era y lou para el
inventor de hecho de la segunda vacuna
de la polio saban que también hoy se usa
ampliamente para ellos era evidente que
esas vacunas tenían que ser sin patentes
sus argumentos eran que eran un bien
público y que además habían desarrollado
sus invenciones con grandes donaciones
de gobiernos entonces pues sabemos que
en parte el hecho de que estas vacunas
fueran tan accesibles son uno de los
motivos por los que hoy en día esta
enfermedad está a punto de ser
erradicadas bueno mares con este
preámbulo entonces ya pasamos a saludar
a nuestra primera invitada al día que es
con nosotros